Speaker 1: All right.
Let's hear from a few more people in our audience.
We take calls weekly via Discord.
You can find our discord at David Pakman dot
com slash discord.
That is the place to go.
Let's try Joe.
Joe from Melbourne, Australia, which can sometimes
go well.
Sometimes Joe Joe's calls get a little risque.
Joe, Joe, what's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Oh, so the.
Bush.
Speaker 1: Jojo.
Speaker 2: Hello?
Hello?
Speaker 1: Jojo, did you have a question for
me today?
Speaker 2: Oh, yeah.
Can you hear me?
Yes.
Oh, hi.
Hi, David.
I do have a question for you.
Yes.
Okay.
I'm going to talk about nepotism.
Did you see the wave of it coming?
Did you think it was abnormal?
So obviously, first of all, there was the
family that took over the White House and
then there's Clarence Thomas and his wife.
This is nothing like.
I would have saved my country anyway.
But it is.
Did you think that was abnormal or was it
just something that.
I think the nepotism.
Speaker 1: In the Trump administration was
particularly brazen, but not altogether surprising.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
I mean, I thought it was in particular, but
then it just kept it off with the Judy Thomas
and Clarence Thomas thing, which I think I
mean, in a normal.
Well, I would think that he would resign his
place in the Supreme Court.
But that's just me.
I'm not sure.
Speaker 1: Yet.
I don't know what the Clarence Thomas thing
is necessarily nepotism.
I think it's more corruption, you know, and
yeah, I don't know that nepotism is the word
I would apply, but it's certainly disgusting,
that's for sure.
Speaker 2: Oh, well, nepotism not not necessarily,
but a what do you call it?
What is it?
Speaker 1: Well, it's certainly corruption.
Speaker 2: Insider trading.
I don't know, I guess.
Speaker 1: Are you interested in a trivia
question?
Can I give you a trivia question?
Speaker 2: Absolutely.
Speaker 1: Can you name countries that start
with the letter J.
Speaker 2: And countries.
Me how it was.
Oh, God.
You put me in front.
Can you give me another letter?
Speaker 1: Well, that's the letter I have.
Joe, Joe, listen, I've got a whole bunch of
people here.
I do have.
Speaker 2: To move on.
And it's very not just jazz.
It is.
Speaker 1: Johannesburg is a city.
Johannesburg is a city.
Speaker 2: No, I know it is.
I know.
I'm really good at geography.
Please give me another one.
Speaker 1: That's the only letter I have.
Jo. Jo, I have to let you go.
I apologize.
Speaker 4: Mm.
Speaker 1: All right.
Jojo.
Okay.
Yes, Jojo from Melbourne, Australia.
Very much appreciated.
Would have accepted Japan, would have accepted
Jamaica and would have accepted Jordan as
well.
All would have been acceptable.
Let's go to Shelley from Indiana.
Shelley, welcome to the program.
What can I do for you today?
Speaker 2: Hi, David.
How are.
Speaker 1: You?
I'm doing well.
Speaker 2: I'm doing great.
So I was just thinking about the governmental
programs and how we have so many people that
disapprove of them.
And I was wondering if the left maybe took
more the approach of what the Swedes do, where
they offer programs to everyone, that no matter
the people, no matter what their income level
is, that way more people would be on board
with it and that it would help people.
Speaker 1: You're saying eliminate means testing
and then maybe there would be less opposition
to social welfare programs in the United States
if everybody just got them.
Speaker 2: Right.
Exactly.
So obviously there would be like people on
the lower end would get more benefits.
But if if the people that made more money
felt like they were still getting something
out of it, then it wouldn't be the blind paying
into it.
And I'm not getting anything from it.
Speaker 1: I totally understand the idea.
I don't think it would make a big difference
to many Republicans, unfortunately.
I think would some it would, but I think with
many it would not.
Speaker 2: Well.
And the reason why why I thought that it might
be a good idea is because when when they were
doing the stimulus checks and there was more
people on the higher end that were still getting,
you saw people that that were really wouldn't
normally approve on those programs that right
happy to get in.
And so it's like well, maybe if we expanded
this where people felt like they were still
getting something out of it.
You.
I don't know.
Speaker 1: It's an idea.
I think it would do a little I don't think
it would make a big difference.
That's my instinct.
Speaker 2: Okay?
Speaker 1: Yeah.
How are things in Indiana?
Things are okay there.
You're welcoming back Mike Pence and everything.
Speaker 2: I'm sure they are not saying that
the weather is right.
So that's good.
Speaker 1: That's good.
Shelley, I appreciate the call.
Speaker 2: All right.
Thank you so much.
Speaker 1: All right.
Shelley from Indiana, always great to hear
from her.